please go to david pakman.com slash
survey we've got a real quick audience
survey that will help direct the future
of the David Pakman show I'd appreciate
it if you took 90 seconds to take care
of that david pakman.com slash survey
new jersey Democratic congressman bill
Pascrell says that a rarely used 1924
law might be used to force Donald
Trump's tax returns into the public bill
Pascrell is on the Ways and Means
Committee and he asked the committee's
chairman Republican Kevin Brady to order
the Treasury Department to provide tax
returns
to the committee and the point of
providing Donald Trump's tax returns to
the committee would be to check for
conflicts of interest check for
connections to Russia all of these other
potential conflicts we've talked about
and despite what Kellyanne Conway has
said people want to see Donald Trump's
tax returns something like 3/4 of
Americans if I recall correctly in a
recent poll said yeah we want to see
Donald Trump's tax returns and what the
1924 law does is it gives congressional
committees that set tax policy the power
to examine specific tax returns and
after privately examining returns the
committee could decide to share them
with the full House of Representatives
if they see that that is something that
should happen which would effectively
make Trump's tax returns public now
again this has rarely been used but it
has been used back in 1974 when Congress
looked at President Richard Nixon's
returns this is the law that was used in
2014 when the Ways and Means Committee
released confidential tax information as
part of that investigation into whether
the IRS was playing politics in terms of
how it handled applications for
nonprofit status it was this law that
was used there now is it likely to
happen cat probably not but there is
precedent here and you mentioned that
3/4 of Americans want to see Donald
Trump's tax returns there was also a
White House petition where 700,000
people signed up you know the position
to get them released in response
Kellyanne Conway said well I don't think
the American people are really
interested in seeing Trump's tax returns
that issue has been litigated yeah
absolutely insane that anyone would
believe that and this is of course
super super important we have all sorts
of information about Donald Trump and
different potential Trump businesses
with China the United Arab Emirates
India Turkey Philippines and of course
Russia is in there as a major major
question mark what's really funny to me
is if Republicans are okay with using
rarely-used rules - shut up Elizabeth
Warren when she wants to read a letter
from Coretta Scott King then they can't
really say because a rule is rarely used
we shouldn't use it here they did the
exact same thing with Elizabeth Warren
and if this is what the letter of the
law says then they don't have a good
foot to stand on to say no we're not
going to allow it I mean if Trump's
Presidency continues to be unpopular I
wouldn't be surprised if some
Republicans in Congress started to
revolt and actually start to demand
themselves to see the returns they want
to impeach him and put pence in there if
they can senator Al Franken recently
revealed on the Bill Maher show and then
also on CNN that he spoke to Republicans
specifically who said they questioned
Donald Trump's mental health but whether
Donald Trump is they think Trump is
mentally ill and you're starting to see
the sort of rumblings of a potential
internal Republican revolt against
Donald Trump his approval rating keeps
dropping and I'm going to address that
probably on tomorrow's show it is just
tanking and you may well see what Pat is
suggesting there